hello everyone and welcome to a bit of a
different
video than i usually do uh here in this
video i'm gonna show you 10 games
by joaquin greco and they are all
all 10 of them are miniatures and if you
guys enjoy we can show
some more but for now it's basically
just a test if you if you guys will
enjoy it
because it's one thing that got me into
chess and got me very interested in
chess because uh
uh even though uh most of them are not
real games they are basically
uh him uh analyzing the openings it's uh
what can happen and to to beginners it
can be
extremely interesting now like i said
it's what it's what got me interested
and hopefully it can do the same for you
now if you've if you already introduced
yourself to greco
uh you know share share the uh knowledge
of greco with with your friends and uh
family
you know at the bar and the library and
uh i remember i don't know if you guys
tried this um this old program called
chess master i remember i had the chess
master grand master edition
and aside from you being able to learn
from for example josh waitskin
in his great academy in there there are
also a list of like a hundred
historical games and the first uh on
that list is a game by joaquin
greco which i will not cover in this
video but i will uh
link to it in the uh in the end of this
video so without further ado let's check
it out i'm not going to dwell
on the history of greco as a lot of it
is uncertain and a lot of it is uh
well miswritten but i will put some
links if you are eager to check that out
as well in the description below as
usual so
uh let's check it out 10 of the games i
didn't go to through any
particular order i just went you know i
just chose the first 10 like i said
there are 89 of them in
in the database so if you guys will
enjoy we're going to check some other
ones so in this one
uh greco has the white pieces and as
usual he will be facing
none other than the hoodie guy and this
just made me realize i forgot to put on
my hoodie so
i'll be right back
all right so we are we are ready this is
game one uh greco versus the hoodie guy
and uh he has the white pieces so e4 by
greco
uh let me just uh
uh fix that uh a little bit uh we have
e5 by mr hoody guy
and now f4 for the first game we're
showing we have the king's gambit we
have e
captures on f4 so the gambit is accepted
and
knight to f3 and here g5 just uh
defending that f4 pawn as you are
expecting d4 and
this pawn will come under attack uh and
then now comes
bishop to c4 we have g4 by black
attacking white's knight and here bishop
captures an f7 so
white is not only uh sacrificing a
bishop but
also we'll see what happens with the
knight here so king captures and now
knight to e5 with check and this is not
all that impressive uh
for white because black can just go back
and black will be fine here however if
you're
a beginner just trying out some openings
and you want to learn more
you might play something like kink to e6
which is what greco's opponent did in
this game
and he attacks the knight so now he
doesn't allow queen captures because
white will lose the knight but this is
exactly what happened in this game so
queen captures and g4
king captures on e5 and now it's just a
wonderful king hunt queen f5
check king to d6 and now even d4
uh we have bishop to g7 bringing a
bishop into the defense and now
bishop captures on f4 we have king to e7
and now
bishop back to g5 with check so the
black king is in check
bishop to f6 and now e5 threatening to
win
a lot of material here so black captures
we have queen captures and g5
king the e8 and now queen to h5 with
check you can either go to f8 or e7
so here e7 was played but now castles
and greco now brings a rook into the
attack
as well we have queen to e8 you don't
want to allow something like
queen f7 or rook f7 so queen to e8
defending but now
again queen g5 check king to e6 and now
our
rook hunt king hunt continues rook to f6
with check so sacrificing the rook as
well
knight captures and queen captures on f6
pushes the king deeper uh into the
position king d5
now knights the c3 and now king capture
sunday for orkin to see for uh both are
equally bad for black
we have queen to f4 with check king to
c5 and now
b4 with check greco with the outmost
precision
king to c6 and now queen to c for with
check the pawn prevents the king from
escaping here so king b6 and now
knight to a4 is checkmate so this is how
greco uh takes down his first opponent
mr hoodie guy number one
and now he will face mr hoodie guy
number two in a different game
so again greco with the white pieces
let's see what happens in this game so
like i said
uh he was uh mostly known for his bishop
opening the the the joko piano
and the king's gambit so uh the the the
older of opening so here we have e4
uh e5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to c4 and i know you guys are
thinking you know where this is going
but it's it's not
bishop to c5 and no we do not have the
evans gambit on the board we actually
have
c3 the joko piano as a greco
is pretty famous for uh inventing his
greco attack
which uh arrives from the uh joko piano
main line
so queen the e7 uh developing the queen
and now castles by white and here d6
greco
immediately strikes in the center with
the d4 and now we have
bishop back to b6 we have bishop to g5
attacking the queen and now uh you
should block it with the knight to f6
but here we have
f6 by black and this allows greco to go
for a very interesting idea bishop to h4
and now g5 further attacking the bishop
but now greco just goes for it knight
captures on g5
we have f captures and now queen to h5
with check so the king is in check
and now you should go kink to d8 this is
a
a safer square for the king however in
the game king the f8 was played
and now there's a problem here bishop
captures on g5 and now you cannot
capture the bishop because queen to f7
is checkmate
so you have to play something else we
have queen to e8 offering a queen trade
but now queen to f3
again with check the bishop covers this
square so the king has to move
king to g7 and now bishop captures on g8
and here
black's only good move is queen to g6
however
in this game rook capture sanjay was
played and now queen to f6
is a wonderful checkmate as the king is
in check and is something for you to
remember
if these two squares are taken away from
the black king and the queen delivers
check
uh it will always be checkmate so
something to keep in mind
so on to game number three this is game
number three and here we have a most
interesting opening the hoodie guy
chooses the fringe defense so let's see
what happens e4
e6 we have d4 and d5 the french defense
is on the board we have
e5 now greco goes for the advanced
variation and now c5
we have c3 uh we have a capture capture
on d4
and now bishop to b4 with check knight
to c3 greco
develops while defending we have
captures captures and now
knight to c6 uh hoodie guy is uh playing
some
some uh vicious chess here uh we have
bishop to d3 greco continues developing
and now
uh knight g to e7 as the f6 square is
taken by the
uh pawn so f4 by greco and now
knight to f5 and excellent square for
the knight so greco continues
development
and here we have castles by hoodie guy
and now it seems like uh
everything is perfectly fine for black
the knights are excellently placed the
king is safely castle but here comes
g4 and now you have uh you have some
problems what are you gonna do with the
knight here
knights the h for his played offering a
trade as the queen covers the h4 square
but now greco just castles and all of a
sudden you can see that all of greco's
pieces are uh
eyeing that king's side the knight is
ready to come into the game the queen
and rook are ready
so we have knight captures on f3 queen
captures and now
bishop to d7 not uh not a good way to
develop this light square bishop as all
of hoodie guys spawns on
light squares so here queen to h3 greco
now
uh threatens checkmate on h7 but now g6
uh and uh it seems again like black is
defending but f5 now
and black's entire position just
crumbles here we have e
captures on f5 g captures and now g
captures on f5 but now
of course this is completely winning for
greco he just plays rook captures on f5
and now there's not much for black to do
king to h8 is a bit of a sturdier
defense
but in this game bishop captures was
played bishop captures and now it was in
this position that
hoodie guy resigned the game as there is
no defense against queen to h7 checkmate
you could prolong the game for a little
bit but
it's uh it's pretty pointless so
another excellent victory for greco and
now we head into one where greco
uh has uh not white but the black pieces
so let's just shift that a little bit so
greco is black here
and we will have another king's gambit
so e4
uh greco also showing that it's possible
to play in great style with black
e5 f4 and e captures on f4 greco now
gladly accepts the gambit we have knight
f3
and g5 now so showing that this is very
much playable for black
bishop to c4 and now even g4
challenging that knight and now comes
knight to e5
with a double attack here and here so
knight to h6 greco defends the f7 pawn
and now
knight captures on g4 we have knight
captures and queen captures
and here greco just goes d5 and this is
by far the strongest idea as it opens up
an attack towards the queen
while attacking the bishop so queen
captures on f4
saying okay you do your your thing i'm
just gonna give check and
capture your rook on h8 so greco says no
problem
i'm going to capture the bishop queen e5
check we have
bishop to e6 blocking the check and now
queen captures on h8 so it seems
mr hoody guy uh tricked greco into
losing material but greco says no
problem
uh queen to h for check and now you have
big problems if g3 just captures here
it's not an issue so king to f1 was
played
but now queen to f4 with check greco
wants every capture to come with a check
so king g1
okay now there are no more chicks but uh
first queen captures an e4
he wants to be ready uh to deliver this
bishop to c5 check
but for the moment he's threatening
queen to e1 checkmate so first you have
to defend against this
h3 now okay uh the king has an escape
square but now
bishop d5 threatening checkmate on g2
so white needs to defend against this
the queen now guards the g2 square but
now
f5 opening up an attack against uh
mr hoodie guy's queen queen back to g3
but now f4 uh attacking the queen even
further and now all of these squares are
covered so you don't really have a good
square here
uh you could go queen to g5 but it
doesn't really it doesn't really do all
that
much f3 is coming so instead uh hood
hoodie guy blocked the f3 square with
the queen
but now only now queen to e1 with check
queen to f1 and now bishop to c5 with
check it's important to cover that the
g1 square with the bishop
king h2 and now comes queen to g3 with
checkmate as the bishop now covers the
g1 square
so here greco shows that it is also
possible to play in great style with the
black pieces
so on to our game five here uh greco
again with the black pieces we again
will have a very nice game off
none other than e4 e5 knight to f3 and
now
f5 something we don't see very often
uh the so-called latvian gambit uh
offers the e5 pawn and
the f5 pawn so white needs to decide
which pawn to take so
knight captures on e5 as it improves the
position of the knight
and now greco takes uh the position of
the knights to bring his
uh queen uh into the game so queen uh f6
attacks the knight and now d4 uh mr
hoodie guy defends his knight
we have uh d6 greco pushes back the
knight and now
knights to c4 and only now f captures on
e4
and okay knight to c3 continuing
development and now
queen to g6 not allowing the bishop to
be developed because the pawn will hang
so here mr hoody guy tries f3 tries to
get the queen into the game but
knight f6 greco just ignores him with f
captures on e4
and now bishop to e7 uh development is
key as greco shows him we know that uh
morphy was the absolute king of
development
but greco uh knew this uh way way before
morphe even started playing chess
uh so bishop to e3 and now knight
captures on e4 greco grabs the pawn in
the center
bishop to d3 pinning the knight and the
now
queen captures on g2 and now what do you
play here
uh queen to h5 is best for mr hoodie guy
but mr hoodie guy uh isn't uh
the greatest of players so he decides to
win material first
bishop captures on e4 but now we have
bishop to h
for check and now there is no move for
mr hoodie guy
he must defend check with the bishop and
now queen captures on f2 and this is now
checkmate as the king has nowhere to go
so those were the the first five and now
on to the second five and these are even
uh
even fiercer so as you know greco is
famous for his use of the greco attack
and this is one of the most beautiful
games where the greco attack was
employed because here greco just plays
it to such
such a level that it's most impressive
so here
again greco is the white and greco has
the white pieces
and we have e4 so i've already told you
we're going to have the greco attack on
the board knight c6 and bishop to c4
bishop to c5 and again not the evans
gambit
unfortunately but the greco's attack is
uh
just as beautiful so knight to f6 and
now d4
starting the the greco attack uh we have
e capture sunday for
c captures on d4 and now bishop to b4
with check and now
knight to c3 uh this is basically the
the beginning of the greco attack but
whenever i see that
line i always kind of think it will go
into the greco attack
knight captures on e4 you sacrifice a
pawn because the knight is pinned and
here
greco just castles uh we have knight
captures on c3
b captures and bishop captures attacking
the rook but now
uh queen to b3 this is the greco attack
at its fullest
and now bishop captures on a1 a move
that is terrible for black but
in those days pretty much everyone took
the rook uh so here bishop captures on
f7
king f8 and then now comes bishop to g5
attacks the queen there is no
move for the uh for the black king uh
queen so
knight has to block and now comes knight
to e1 uh
also rook to e1 is a very strong move
rook captures here is a very strong move
but greco continues in great style and
goes for knight to e5
with d5 by black and now comes queen to
f3
threatening some nasty discoveries after
the bishop moves with bishop to f5
now blocking uh the queen's attack
towards the king
and now bishop to e6 with a double
attack on the knight here
and here we have g6 adding another
defender but now comes
bishop to h6 check king to e8 and now
the incredible bishop to f7 checkmate
sort of reminding you of the of the uh
immortal game by adolf anderson
as the the bishops are doing a wonderful
job here
these two squares are covered and the
king has nowhere to go
so amazing amazing game so uh on to our
next game
here uh greco again has the white pieces
and this is a really short one
so let's just dive straight into it also
features the king's gambit e4 e5 and
of course f4 the king's gambit uh e
captures and
now uh we have bishop to c4 the bishop
is gambit to the king's gambit
queen to h4 with check king to f1 of
course blocking uh
and now uh bishop to c5 already
threatening checkmate on f2
but now d4 this is a very well known
line
for white and the white has nothing to
worry about here
bishop back to b6 and now comes knight
to f3 now white uses the uh awkward
placement of the black king to develop
pieces
and now you should go back quinta d8 is
best however here
queen to g4 was played and now i know
you don't even
need to pause the video to win this game
uh so i'll i'm just going to show you
bishop captures on f7 with check and now
black's position is already terrible but
just for the sake of this game black
captured on f7 and now comes 95 check
with a beautiful fork
and of course after king of fate knight
captures uh black resigned the game so
another excellent victory for
for greco on the game eight uh where
greco again has the white pieces and
again a very short one but a nice one
e4 e5 knight f3 knight to c6 uh sorry
knight to f6 here uh hoodie guy goes for
the petra of defense
and now knight captures on e5 so the
classical variation of the petrov
nothing
spectacular but here hoodie guy goes for
knight captures on e4
and this is something you don't play uh
here greco attacks the knight and now if
you just move back the knight
then it's an immediate win by knight to
c6 check
and you will lose the queen by either
blocking with the bishop and then knight
picks up the queen or you're going to
block with the queen and then the knight
captures the queen so you cannot do this
so instead we have queen to e7 by black
but not just queen captures on e4 and
here it's
uh very interesting black plays d6
now the queen uh the knight cannot move
because the queen hangs so here just
d4 by greco we have f6 by mr hoodie guy
and f4 by greco and now knights to d7
just piling up on that knight because
the knight can never move
so here knights to c3 and now finally d
captures on e5 winning back that night
with knights the d5 by greco
you have to be careful where you put the
queen because knight c7 check will pick
up
material so queen to d6 defending c7 but
now
d captures on e5 we have f captures and
f
captures on e5 attacking the queen uh we
have queen back to c6 and now comes a
beautiful
bishop to b5 and again you cannot
capture the bishop because now with
the with the monster royal fork knight
c7 would win the game
so instead after bishop b5 we have queen
to c5 but
it's not much better bishop to e3 by
greco and the queen is trapped all of
the squares here are covered you cannot
go to any square
uh so you might as well grab some
material queen captures on b5 was played
but now knight c7 check king to d8 and
now
knight captures on b5 wins the game for
greco
so on to game number 9 again a very
short one here
greco has the black pieces so let's just
shift them
we have e4 e5 and now bishop to c4 white
goes for the bishop's opening
and now knight to f6 greco also did some
serious work on the bishop's opening
knight to c3 and now c6 preparing to
strike in the center with d5
queen f3 and now b5 even charging the
bishop this way
b3 and b4 now forcing the knight to move
knights to a4 and now comes d5 so exon
development in the center by greco
pushing that knight all the way to the
side of the board d3 by mr hoodie guy
and now
h6 and here you have to be very very
careful
uh we have knights to e2 and now white
says
okay i'm uh doing pretty well here i can
castle i can continue developing but
here greco sets a trap
d4 and now white is in a terrible
position unless he plays a good move
here which is usually the case interest
white needs to go queen to g3 and he
will be fine however
white said i'm just going to go knight
to g3 instead because i want to get my
knight
to this very nice f5 square but now
white is completely lost and i'm sure
you know why
uh without even pausing the video so i'm
just going to congratulate all of you
for finding it
bishop to g4 and the queen is trapped
the d4 move
was simply setting up this queen uh
queen trap as the the e3 square has been
taken away from the white queen
so the queen has nowhere to go and of
course uh it was in this position that
mr hoodie guy
resigned the game and for the last game
and this is a really a beautiful one uh
greco again with the white pieces so
let's just give him the white pieces
opens with e4 uh for some reason e4
uh is not uh happening oh yeah there it
is e4 e5 and again
f4 so uh the king's gambit once again
we are in in good luck in this video e
captures and bishop to c
for now we have queen to h for check
again mr hoodie guy tries the same idea
king f1
and bishop to c5 now threatening
checkmate on f2
but now comes d4 so let's see if mr
hoodie guy
does better this time bishop to b6 and
now knight to f3
again attacking the queen last time we
saw that queen g4 loses the bishop
characters on f7 so this time mr hoodie
guy learned
queen back to e7 and now bishop captures
an f4 and now you should just continue
d6
or developing in some way however mr
hoody guy again got greedy played queen
captures on e4
and this now again doesn't work bishop
captures an f7
mr hoodie again falls for the same trap
well almost because if king captures
knight g5 check wins the queen
so mr hoody guy did not accept the
bishop sacrifice instead he played the
king to f8
but now comes bishop to g3 and it's
already a very difficult position to
play for black so
knights the h6 he goes after the bishop
and now knight to c3 and in between move
before reacting to this is now black's
queen is under attack so black's queen
needs to move
queen back to e7 and now bishop back to
b3
and now you're gonna make you're gonna
try and use the file to go after the
black king
so here c6 and now queen to d3 preparing
to bring this rook
into the game we have d5 by black
cutting off the light square bishop from
the game
uh but that's only temporary so here
rook to e1
attacking the queen and queen to f6 now
and bishop to h4
attacking black's queen queen to g6 and
here comes
bishop to e7 check so not trading queens
just yet
waiting for king to g8 but now now only
now greco goes for queen captures on g6
and it's not very often you will see
greco trading queens because he usually
just checkmates his opponents
so here he does it uh for a very good
reason because after h captures on g6
here
white goes for the absolute best knight
captures on the e5
and here whatever you play is bad but
for the sake of uh argument uh we have c
captures on d5
bishop captures with check and now uh
nothing for you to play if you block
with the knight which is the best
thing to do here white just brings
another attacker into the game
or knight e5 even better so here king
the h7 was played and now we finally
reach the position from the thumbnail
knight to g5 and this is now checkmate
as the bishops
do their job covering any escape squares
and knight g5 a beautiful smothered mate
uh so yeah this is game 10 uh of uh the
greco series uh i don't know if you guys
enjoyed it but i remember when i was
starting out uh greco's games were
one of my favorite even though they
aren't actually games they're some of
them are games some of them are him just
doing analysis but
they were definitely uh one of my
favorites so i do hope you guys enjoyed
that as well
if you want more we can do uh more of
greco's games
like in uh let's say uh 10 10 games
in in a video or maybe five if 10 is too
much for you i don't know uh comment and
you know
good things will happen so yeah uh those
are the 10 greco games i do hope you
guys enjoyed it and if you would enjoy
another one
uh yell and i made a video on on uh one
of
greco's greatest games uh not so long
ago it was a
uh april's fool's day video uh but it's
actually a very serious video so if you
wanna check that out as well it will be
the first link in the description below
uh so yeah that's it hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
sri darapatar luis medrano nathan
bennett george dale and fresh stolen
memes for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
do do mention if you would like to see
more greco's games
in a video such as this one see you soon